what's your favorite NBA jersey you own
besides your own I have a Kobe jersey
I've been having since I was in like
fifth grade I used to wear it all the
time who is the most famous person in
your contact probably Drake I hear
you're a big Lamar Jackson Guy what's
your Super Bowl prediction probably
49ers versus the Ravens you can only
listen to one album for the rest of your
life what would it be Love Is rageed by
Uzi if you could have a ticket to any
game in sports history what would it be
2010 B finals what's your favorite
basketball sneaker Kyrie what's the
toughest Road Arena to play in probably
Utah pretty good fans and they got a
really good team if you could have one
basketball related superpower what would
it be probably shooting the ball like at
a really high level you know a leite